flippy from indiana
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend hi can you hear
me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only fans sorry if i if i've
done making an omelette what no no
making it only fans uh you know uh
gardening season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory i hear the sound of
winning
winning
[Music]
winning winning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already suppression falls we you
can't hold them i'm soaking wet already
suppression falls now yesterday we had
three big ones really big suppression
balls and don't give me the umbrella i'm
soaking wet already they put numbers you
know they're called suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly so you say your wife you said
your husband darling let's go out to
dinner and then we'll come back we love
our president but you know the polls say
he can't win well right now we're
leading
in almost everywhere the real the
leading
[Music]
one already suppression balls
red
[Music]
suppression balls
[Music]
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that look at that that
who thinks is smarter than you why he
thinks he's smarter than you
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shot
jones has
[Music]
trump was doing this with
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elephants and bathrooms
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me look at that
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
world war cuz pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children
your destiny
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
mangoes my bad the mangos
i love mangoes too
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
all right welcome everybody it is an
incredible day i'm so glad to be joined
by so many of you i am taking this
stream so seriously that i actually
showered in or out of respect to the
audience uh the lovers and the haters
out of pure deep down respect
i did take a shower before today's
stream we are standing by for the cpac
2022
keynote address from former president
donald trump
donald trump yeah donald trump right uh
probably the only president i can
remember who has sometimes misstated his
own name his own name then he went
donald trump yeah donald trump exactly
um if uh any of you ever forget
that the american right wing
is sick and disgusting and deranged
cpac
is our annual reminder i guess uh is
what we are going to say uh i did have
to plunge my shower 10 to 15 times
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times exactly
and for people who are really mostly
here just for fruit related commentary i
have a fridge full of granny smith
apples and sumo oranges and
depending on how the stream goes we'll
uh we'll get into some fruit and things
will really get very very crazy on the
stream now i do want to make sure
everybody knows we are simultaneously in
addition to cpac we are monitoring
multiple streams from ukraine where
there are unfortunately numerous reports
that we may be just an hour from
a huge
bombing in kiev
with the possibility that tonight is
when putin attempts to take heave and so
we're gonna be we're gonna be monitoring
that as well
um a couple different things along those
lines wait a second let me see one
person that is interesting to follow is
uh ilya
a defense reporter with the kiev
independent
now i wanna again restate
many of the things that have come out of
ukraine during this conflict end up
being revised and they end up not being
the way things are
that being said
i would follow elia panamarenko um and
you know let's evaluate everything
that's being said the most recent tweet
14 day 14 minutes ago is a statement
from the ukrainian military that all
attacks on kharkiv have been repelled
um
firearms and body armor coming in to
support ukraine from lithuania
and
maybe
uh
the the most concerning part here
extremely heavy russian air raid
expected in kiev within minutes that was
two hours ago and we're still continuing
to see uh what is going on i want to say
thank obama prompt for the first super
chat who says hi david thank you for the
frequent live streams current events are
pretty depressing right now i appreciate
how you simultaneously take things
seriously but also provide a little
levity at times thank you obama obama
exactly
um okay so that's ilya panamarenko
someone to follow very strongly
and uh the next the next event is trump
uh so far everything has been on uh on
schedule today trump is rarely on
schedule but it looks like
maybe today he will be on schedule in
which case we would expect to hear from
him very very soon i wanna say a huge
thank you and shout out to luanne ruff
luann just signed up on my website with
the coupon code wow 22 and his new
member number one today
also want to say thanks to some great
people supporting from twitch and again
thank you thank you thank you to all of
our new followers on twitch it's been
our best week in
a really really really long time on
twitch and i want to say thanks to jen
here for the sub and the gift artistic
simplicity dirt nap focused apathy ita i
and friends
robin your rhubarb is number seven and
tina teru number eight eight plus one is
nine and then five gifted subs from our
great friend captain smiles
puts a set 14
um and i can't tell you how much i
appreciate everybody's support i do have
one completely lunatic email i'm sorry
this is a uh facebook message i want to
let you guys know that we are under
attack ever since alex jones went after
me we have been under serious attack
pac-man's a loser exactly uh this
message coming in via facebook the
message is as follows
you suck
don't want you to be mistaken somehow
you reach my video stream and instantly
i knew your view was a screwed rich weak
pathaic view
though i hope you life is not
meaningless i feel your effects hears on
earth are and i hope you look to a
common sense view to determine
liberalism
liberalism here in america is falling
because where we may not be savage
the world still is so having a
conservative stance
is still more valuable
than
your pathetic liberal view
heart everybody
heart okay very very important message
and we will ban men exactly so
uh would it shock you to know that this
is a cpa who does people's taxes that
sent this would that be surprising to
anybody
this could be your kid's pediatrician
probably not probably not okay
um
so anyway we are very very strongly
under attack and that is not a good
thing super chat's coming in haley says
sir sir
can we do trump bingo again do i have
sir here hold on i don't even know what
i'm doing sir wait sir sure there it is
um no trump bingo today i just ran out
of time
i had company
um stay in grab some z pack and watch
deepak cover cpac says daniel please
proceed governor thank you
scott says david could you give a simple
breakdown of how cutting russia out of
swift will have a drastic impact on
russia as reports suggest okay here's
the thing with swift now i want to make
it really really i i want to give you
guys all sides of an issue
swift is essentially an inter i'm going
to do my best to explain it swift that's
capital sw ift all caps swift is like an
inter bank almost like a messaging
system and it's used for international
bank transfers
and the idea here is
if you
cut russia from their ability to use
swift all of a sudden they can't move
money they can't buy stuff etc it would
be devastating to russia the
counterpoint i've read is that that very
same swift system is used by many
european countries to pay russia
for natural resources including i
believe oil from which gasoline is
derived so what you don't want is a
situation where by cutting russia out of
swift
all of a sudden europe is short on gas
which i hate gas i wish we were all on
electric and vehicles and all this
different stuff but
if you're trying to resist russia at
least for now you're going to need some
gasoline so
i don't
i don't want you and then so can we get
gas to those countries yes hopefully
hopefully i just want to make sure
everybody knows that there are sort of
like a couple different aspects to that
david what day and time do you take live
calls wednesdays at 12 15 p.m eastern
u.s time
kevin david thank you for the time and
effort you put into your show recently
became a member it's kept me sane
experiencing world events with you and
other fans i really appreciate that i'm
so glad you're here kevin
so glad you're here
thoughts of donations with bitcoin for
ukraine i have i don't i heard they're
accepting donations via bitcoin via
bitcoin but i don't know too too much
about it yet what i do want to mention
though is that there have been some
major developments in terms of airspace
prohibitions
russian airplanes have been banned
from flying over ukraine since 2015
but there are now very very powerful
extremely extremely strong
new bands
russian
aircraft can no longer fly over estonia
latvia lithuania poland
the czech republic slovenia romania
bulgaria and the united kingdom which as
you can see includes that entire area in
the guys remind me what body of water is
that
between france and the uk
what's that body of water
hold on let me see here
that's the
well the english channel no but it's
part of the north sea okay yeah very
good
uh now you might be wondering what is
this little red area oh sorry this
little blue area here where russia can
still fly that's an interesting area
it's this little tip
it's just really the tip of northern
europe that's where kaliningrad and
other russian elements are
it's sort of like an outpost
uh svetlagorsk is also there
and uh a lot a lot of interesting
historic it's a it's a national it's
it's basically just it's a tip of a
russian enclave exactly
so that's pretty strong i'm not gonna
lie and things are going to get more and
more difficult for russia now
additionally i want to make sure you
guys know that um ukrainian president
zielenski
is doubling down very strongly and he
may lose his life
he may lose his life but he was told
apparently that u.s officials are
willing to get him out if if he needs to
get out and he said guys i don't need a
ride
i need bullets
i need bullets and i'm here to fight and
i may die it is
horrifying what is happening in ukraine
horrifying but
you can't help but respect zelinski and
by the way
not a particularly popular guy
if he were to survive
he could end up one of the most popular
world leaders in the world if he were to
survive i worry he will not survive
i worry he will not survive
um the counterpoint is what if he is
taken alive by russia and then
who the hell knows what happens
um
it's
it's it's crazy it's crazy what's going
on
uh what else did i have here
russia meets fierce ukrainian resistance
as troops pressed towards kiev yeah
uh here is the here is the russian the
ukrainian president
right
what he's basically the point he's
making here as i understand is that he's
he's in kiev he's not leaving
that is
i am not joking he's saying it very very
strongly and the next 24 hours from what
i'm from when i'm reading could be
absolutely crucial absolutely crucial
um other super chats john smith asks why
democrats win in rich cities and
republicans in poor cities but rich
people vote republican and poor
democrats that's so extensive your
question i couldn't possibly address
that right now john but i will try to do
it in the future
do you think economically isolating
russia may turn the russian citizens who
seem to be against war against the west
honestly no
no
spacex starling terminals enroute to
ukraine very strongly musk tweeted okay
i'm gonna look into that
if only my trump or parents knew i was
spending my night watching this predator
that is a freaking predator right there
keep up the great work david thank you
david any chance of a behind the scenes
video to show your youtube setup and
team members maybe
maybe
preston says the russians are using
mobile crematoriums is it crematoriums
or crematoria
for some reason it feels like it would
be crematoria
to cover up evidence of their own losses
totally inhumane and disgusting yeah
that is vile if true that is vile if
true
let's make sure we're all set here
okay uh welcome everybody if you're just
joining us the the big event tonight is
the keynote at cpac where uh donald
trump is expected to speak uh
momentarily in about 25 minutes we are
also of course monitoring what's going
on in ukraine there have been reports
that in the next a few hours
um vladimir putin is going to try to
take keefe
and we are going to be watching that we
are going to be watching that couple of
other things for you guys let me see
what i've got
um oh it appears as though again
everything's moving so quickly we just
don't know
but the cyber the elements of cyber they
may be attacking russia cyberly i guess
is what i mean six russian government
websites including the kremlin website
are down
after the government of ukraine asked
for volunteers from the country's hacker
underground six russian government
websites including the kremlin site are
down
completely down from what i understand
the exact reasons are not immediately
clear
but the international hacking group
anonymous claimed it was attacking the
sites some russian sites continue to be
down saturday
the websites that are dark notably
include the kremlin and the ministry of
defense
gaslus lugi
russia's web portal of state services
went offline saturday night as well so
it appears as though anonymous is uh
carrying out operations
and uh
that is that is
that is certainly something that is
certainly something i want to make sure
i continue thanking everybody who's
supporting us today
chameleon has subscribed via twitch
embers has subscribed and gifted too
and billy carpenter has resubscribed for
five months putting us at 19. also a
huge thank you to david mays who just
signed up with the coupon code cpac
trash i don't think i have to explain
that one to anybody
david love the show please talk about
what's going on for trans kids in texas
we covered that on the bonus show i
believe
yeah oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad
sir are you familiar with rm brown
recently started following in rece and
enjoys coverage i don't know anything
about rm brown other than once one of
their viewers i don't know if it's a guy
or a gal called in and i thought they
said arun brown like the indian name
arun brown and i didn't know who that
was and i still don't know who r.m brown
but i know
it's not arun it's rm that i know i've
been told
do you think putin's crazy enough to
launch a nuke i'm going to continue with
no i can't
i i'm going to continue saying no
if nato troops are brought in to assist
evacuating refugees and are killed by
russian russian soldiers in the
crossfire what would happen
um i think more troops would be sent in
and
it would get very very ugly
i swear this is the last talk about this
i just feel bad i asked why hassan's
take was different leading up to the war
i don't want him to seem like he is alt
left like tulsi
love you obama okay thank you joshua
everything's fine you don't have to
apologize to me
david found your live stream from the
2020 trump riots love the show and the
live streams keep up the good work thank
you james
and bay photo says what do we think will
trump continue his gleeful praise for
putin or tone it down either way it
wouldn't have happened if he was
president yes i think guaranteed trump
tonight says this never would have
happened if i were president
i assume that someone has gone to trump
and said stop calling putin a genius for
what he's doing
and my guess
is that trump is likely to listen to it
that's my prediction as of right now
and if you guys have a different
perspective by all means let me know
also in the news
um
here's more oh here's more on the uh the
um
assault that's expected any moment now
we are on a state and height of a
heightened state of alert even a state
and height i like that's actually genius
a state and height
that was i actually love that we are on
a state and height of a heightened state
of alert even here in kiev
we've been told by ukrainian security
forces to take our position down off the
roof which we had also to try to use as
little light as possible because the
anticipation is now that in the coming
hours or frankly minutes we just don't
know
there could be a major assault on this
city and i think the assumption is that
that might include pretty serious aerial
bombardment we really don't know any
details yet we're just being given
instructions
by ukrainian officials also the hotel
alert system has been going off uh
instructing people all of these
reporters
stay safe that was at 1204 a.m cave time
it's now 1 39 a.m keeve time
and so uh
i mean listen we're
all we can do is watch all of it
um
a couple other things i wanted to
go over here
um
matt gates involved in the entertainment
at cpac i guess
[Music]
extraordinarily cringy
um
last night marjorie taylor green
headlined a neo-nuts basically a
neo-nazi rally a white supremacist rally
involving some kid named nick fuentes
and others and today she said she
doesn't know anything about it but i'm
glad to talk to you about this i do not
know nick fuentes i've never heard him
speak i've never seen a video i don't
know what his views are so i'm not
aligned with anything that may be
controversial but i can tell you
anything bad she's not affiliated with
went to his event last night to address
his very large following because that is
a young it's a very young following and
it's a generation i'm extremely
concerned about it's a way to teach me
excuse me i'll tell you exactly why i
went i went to talk to them about
american first policy she went to talk
to white white nationalists about
america first which is their own slogan
so it's it's absolutely perfect guys
that's that's what it's all about
uh let's see what else we've got here
let's see
ladies and gentlemen it's time for
locker up for real
god it is quite a day quite a day at uh
cpac then sebastian gorka gorka sounds
like someone choking there have been
tens of thousands of americans who say
no
fauci go to hell
i'm an american
i have the right to feed my children you
will not mask my children go to hell how
does masking a kid prevent you from
feeding them does anybody know i mean i
like i know i i in a literal sense i
know like while you're wearing the mask
you can't eat because the mask covers
your mouth if you're wearing it
correctly although many people wear it
like a chin diaper
but how does that even you guys don't
know either okay
yeah you don't have to wear masks at
home that's true
or even better
go to prison right
um here's more covet disinformation
this virus is spread from a symptomatic
person
to a susceptible person only was this
the guy who went on rogan and said all
sorts of lies
there is negligible asymptomatic spread
that doesn't seem to be true
and you tell dr fauci to stick those
vaccines where the sun don't shine
god bless you all god bless america
yeah
man that's
that is something huh guys and god bless
the united states
ladies and gentlemen this is fire fouchy
[Music]
oh man that needs to be on a loop
ladies and gentlemen this is fire fouchy
a real meeting of the minds huh
what a humiliation
what a humiliation
um guess we have a few more minutes
here's kyle rittenhouse saying he might
sue biden because he just wanted to talk
to biden and biden wouldn't meet with
him let's talk about these these
lawsuits that you're thinking about with
lebron james whoopi goldberg and maybe
probably are you going to sue the
president united states
the president of the united states
called me a white supremacist and he i
reached i tried reaching out to him five
times to have an interview but he was
listen kyle i've also reached out to
biden five times to have an interview
okay outwardly to sit down and talk to
me so we may be sending him a letter
um what would the letter say
i want him to apologize what he said was
wrong i want him to sit down with me and
i want him to learn the facts of what
happened can you imagine
desperately desperately
clinging to any last bit of relevance
that he can
uh wow it's almost like sad in some
weird way but it's like not oh this was
moments ago javelin's a lot of them too
and i guess that's uh
helping a lot
mr mr president yeah please go ahead
good um i have a question for you about
one of your pals from your friends
um text messages were recently released
from recently released from the january
sixth committed committee sit by sean
hannity on january 6 in it it appears
that he's contradicting
what you were trying to tell your staff
that day and at least text messages to
one senior staffer
do you still consider hannity a friend
an ally
well i don't know what messages you're
talking about but i think he's a great
gentleman a very talented person he gets
fantastic ratings is he all sweaty he
speaks well of me he agrees with what
i'm saying so i really don't know i
haven't seen him
oh i haven't seen him no i haven't heard
about him receiving
he was oh my god
mr president uh during your whole
administration slogan promises made
promises kept gets resonated last year
you promised to roll out a social media
platform that all americans can jump on
to secure their voice
just two weeks ago you wrote out true
social yeah would you please comment on
the success of this rollout and how
significant it is in our culture of
communication well i think it's been an
incredible success i mean
almost no one can even get on it the
people trying to get on and we're doing
it very slowly you know you opened
something like that i had hundreds of
millions of people all of a sudden we
had nobody we had no voice
and now we're going to have a very
strong voice again
we have uh tremendous as you see and
we're getting tremendous reviews too on
the platform itself
but it's uh no you're not dude people
are getting on and they're loving the
product and we're getting
they literally cloned twitter
well we'll be doing it pretty soon
i wanted to hold on a little bit but
people are loving it as you know
and i love the fact that we got the word
truth is a great word mexico right now
the app as as of this morning the
waiting list is closing in on one
million people has that even exceeded
your expectations
i thought it would do very well i've
done very well in this world and the
answer is no trump thought 200 million
people would sign up be happy about they
love it once they get on and the
list of people wanting to get on is
record-breaking
not really
yeah please
whatever his name is right
and you know he's not abandoning his
people he's saying and taking up arms
with his countrymen if you were in a
similar situation as president would you
take up arms like velensky no well you
know you never know about bravery some
people think they're brave and they're
not brave and people don't think of
themselves yeah trump's gonna take up
arms guys oh my god get the hell out of
here and
he's being tested at the highest level
and so far he's really shown great
leadership and great guys it's obvious
just from this trump has been told to
stop praising putin and has been told
the p the people are on the side of
ukraine he clearly someone clearly got
to him you won't have to need that too
much longer because maybe things can end
this should not happen this should never
have happened
well that's what he thinks i believe he
does think that and it's probably true
but he's showing great bravery what was
the question
mr president the department of justice
under your administration opened up a
basically a china espionage initiative
now the department of justice has shut
that down what are your thoughts well
i'm surprised they did we were very
careful with that at china as you know
is a is a very big player but it's a
uh sir have you ever urinated on anyone
in russia ways especially in that we had
it very well shut down and now they're
opening it up and i'm surprised to see
that i don't think we should be doing
that but that's what they want to do
that's what they want to do i think it's
a big mistake pretty good
questions confident in the election
integrity measures that have been
instituted by certain legislators in
pennsylvania particularly are you
concerned about this fault well a lot of
things are going on in pennsylvania as
an example many subpoenas are out the
evidence is coming out any day guys
corruption that we've all seen that i've
seen any day when you look at the uh
ballot harvesting that has been like
hundreds of thousands of votes and this
is just now coming out and we have it on
tape they have it on pings 16 months
later we're finally gonna get the
evidence guys and it's conclusive and
it's determinative but pennsylvania i
know as uh as you know over the last
three or four months they've become very
active because they found out that i
believe they found out now that
now that it's 2022 they're really
getting active at figuring out what
happened two years ago
i don't know that the effects are good i
know that i think they're finding out
what happened
more importantly right now because you
really have to find out what happened in
order to properly fix it and i think
they have some very good leadership
right now in pennsylvania that and i'm
not talking about the governor who
doesn't want anything to do with it
because he understood what happened but
we have some very good republican
leadership in pennsylvania and they're
finding out tremendous things that took
place during the day guys i'm starting
to think the evidence may not be about
to come out i don't know about you guys
pennsylvania and other mostly swing
states probably other states also but
the illusion
the swing states mr president how
concerned are you that china might move
on taiwan
based on what's happening right now with
ukraine and are there also concerns well
the virus came from china and it never
should have happened well to go back in
and reunify it but we did very well with
north korea as you remember we were
supposed to go to war with north korea
we never came close
kim jong-un very well
we had a very good relationship a lot of
people said it's terrible that he had a
relationship well we had a very good
relationship
uh we got along and we didn't have
nuclear holocaust we didn't have because
he has a lot of nukes and a lot of
different
we know exactly wait a second does north
korea actually have the ability to
deliver a nuclear warhead what is he
saying is
i i didn't think north korea had that
capability like what is he talking about
i've been saying for a long while now
that
wait a second does trump wrongly think
north korea has the ability to launch a
nuclear missile and the fact that they
didn't he thinks is because of him is
that is it possible that's what trump
believes in ukraine right now i think
when putin saw that and when president
xi of china witnessed that i think he
has a whole different design right now
than he would put on the earth
i think they looked at that and and so
it grossly incompetent
uh losing soldiers you know when i was
president kim jong-un went four years
didn't launch a single nuke at the
united states yeah but sir does he have
that capability well i don't know but he
didn't do it
having the military move first
i think it's one of the most
embarrassing moments and i really think
that's a contributing factor to what's
happening today in ukraine and i think
it's going to also lead to a similar
thing happening in taiwan they wanted to
get the olympics finished the olympics
are now finished
let's see what happens you know
yesterday bombers i actually do agree
that it it strikes me
as
something that china would be all of a
sudden saying hey let's let's think
about taiwan i've been saying that for
weeks i actually agree with trump on
this chuck todd said the other day
how come he was talking to blanken or
somebody
he said how come this never happened in
the four years that president trump was
there that was a shocking question
and they were unable to answer that
question
someday i'll write a book and i'll tell
you why it never happened but it never
happened
there's a very very important question
to be asked
what is the one sanction or the two
sanctions that have not been implemented
to stop vladimir putin that you would
implement given a trump presidency
sanctions now you have to understand
sanctions are very expensive for our
country also but the one that people are
talking about which is very very severe
as you know is swift
and that just really destroys a banking
system of a country
it's a very big step
and we'll see whether or not that step
is taken but
it is thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people could die with us
and this could spread to other
countries and it could spread throughout
the world i mean this could be a world
war
something has to be done should have
never started and it did
and something has to be done so that
would be the one that seems to be they
did it on most people's minds well they
did it so you should praise biden right
that seems to be the one that's the
situation the most powerful what should
be done if you were friends they did it
they did it
now but you say it wouldn't have gotten
here
what should joe biden do
he did it i think i know exactly what
should be done number one we shouldn't
be here but on the assumption that we're
here that's a big assumption but it's
happened
uh we uh there are things that he should
do i would rather not tell him under
this forum i don't think it's
appropriate to say that but there are
things he could do that would be very
strong very powerful and i think we
ended pretty quickly
but remember this
looking at the greatest nuclear power
when i was in office i had it rebuilt
modernized
and also rebuilt our military also
started space force which has a lot to
do with what we're talking about
but with the greatest nuclear power
but russia has an almost equal nuclear
power this is beyond parity china is
five years behind but they have very
substantial
nuclear power
we all have to be very careful we're
gonna have to leave it there thank you
all and thank you god bless you thank
you the family's doing well hope the
families do thank you all very much
thank you
and we will love you
someone said love you too mr president
that was weird very strong journalism
questions okay we are now potentially
just five ten minutes away it looks like
trump was answering a few questions
before his speech is going to start
let's thank people who are here and are
helping let's see
i want to say thank you too
uh skittlestu for gifting two
subscriptions on twitch the rhetorics
lord lebrand
frisky seal why not those are five
putting us at 25 i also want to send out
peace and love greetings to richard
johnson who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code cpac trash
marilyn brown
and daniel mickel all signing up on my
website with the coupon code cpac trash
some coupon codes like obama obama
require an explanation
some coupon codes like cpac trash really
require no explanation uh we're
continuing to monitor the situation in
different parts of ukraine including
kiev which is
you know i don't want to use the term
rumored
there is concern that keeve could fall
tonight
okay so we're watching that also thanks
to philosophy doggo for the twitch prime
subscription number 29. all right let's
do something guys i i do have to ask you
for a favor okay
uh and that favor is very specific i
need 11 000 votes give me a break no i
didn't it's not it's not that kind of
favor everybody relax it's not that kind
of favor
um we are actually under a concert i did
a segment last week where i called out
the alt left the alt left is not the
tanky revolutionary left the alt left
are people like glenn greenwald and
tulsi okay as a result
their sycophants are coming right after
us here's one such example here's robert
who said david i have unsubscribed from
your show
because you revealed your our tribal
tulsi gabbard speaks to citizens of all
labels calling us to remember our
comment
okay so the tool c's are toll cells some
people are calling them
they are abandoning the show and that's
okay i don't need them
i want good people like you guys
involved and so my one request for you
today today is day six in a row of
consecutive streams and we're gonna keep
going
get a membership on my website
they can't use swift banking against us
they can't we control the whole process
they can't ban us facebook youtube we
control the whole process okay you get
an extra show every day you get the show
six hours before everybody else you can
use the coupon code cpac trash if you
want you can use the coupon code obama
if you want
and i will shout out every single one of
you who gets a membership today it's our
primary source of funding and
number 30 we're at 29 number 30 i will
throw in a free item from my online
store which includes coffee mugs tea
mugs water mugs juice well i get it a
mug you can put anything in it
a hat
t-shirt hoodie sweatshirt whatever you
want a free item we will ship it to you
anywhere in the world for number 30 at
joinpackman.com okay and i will shout
out everybody let's go to some of these
uh super chats that are coming in which
is likely to happen first republican
health care plan or election evidence of
fraud in a dumpster behind the four
season sex shop i would that's i would
split i would double down that's a 50
50. i couldn't possibly guess there
yet you can even put soup in the mug
soup for your family that's exactly
right soup for your family
we are standing by
for president donald trump we are
watching what's happening in ukraine
it is an incredible evening i'm so glad
to be joined by so many of you
um what do you believe david would
happen if russia nuked ukraine because
they want the world to forget ukraine i
think hell would rain down on russia the
likes of which we've never seen
if that were to happen
it's my opinion
it's my opinion
um let's oh people want a couple of
voicemails sure i'll do a couple
voicemails
let's see here
mr pac-man sir why aren't you covering
all the people that are suddenly dying
of causes but it obviously relates to
the vaccine you know look betty white
bob sag my 99 year old grandma all these
people suddenly dead oh
it's obviously from the vaccine you were
fake news david pac-man
oh
you are a predator alex jones is right
that is a freaking predator that's
satire just to make sure everybody knows
that satire that is complete satire that
is not a serious voicemail very nicely
done
uh let's see what else we've got whitney
wanging weighing in on the geopolitical
issue of our day
so is it just me or did you notice that
um when russia went in to invade
that it looked like they killed a bunch
of civilians
and nobody retaliated
and then they killed two soldiers
and then all of a sudden like they were
like [ __ ] you and then like took off
and also
i got the feeling that uh benjamin
shapiro is hebrew he's not hebrew he's
jewish he's jewish whitney everybody
relax okay everybody relax
uh he he is he is not hebrew
um okay
yeah things are getting a little weird
here
let's see if we let's see if we even
want to hear from anybody else here
uh david pegman what is really
disgusting me about this ukraine russian
conflict
is some of the reaction on youtube and
the internet oh good for you troy very
very good glad glad to hear it
uh let's see if i've got anybody else
anything else to play for you guys i
mean i have a lot of stuff it's just
most of it is so delusionally weaponized
that i don't want to kind of like ruin
an otherwise nice evening with you fine
folks
um
oh hold on new member number 30. here we
go
scott labrie is new member number 30
using the coupon code cpac trash
and uh scott you've won a free item from
our online store email info at
davidpakman.com
to get it
let's see if we get to 45. i'll give
another one away at 45. tungsten mum
it's leah mccaufield blc marcus and
piercy just got twitch prime
subscriptions let's see if we can get to
45. if we get to 45 i'll give away
another item
mike snow using the code cpac trash is
number 35.
emily larson is number 36
damien garvey is number 37.
hiroko nakayama is number 38
charlotte roy is number 39. andrew
jannik is number 40. robert slavins is
number 41. okay i'll give away another
item at 45. let's see if we make it
tim o'hearn
is number
42. jeff carr is number 43. susan
zalakowski is number 44
and that's all i got right now okay i'll
i'll give away another item at 45. sure
i'll do it
let's look at some super chats in the
meantime say key false tonight is it
still to be determined that the west
will intervene or do you think it's
completely off the table i believe biden
is going to stick to no boots on the
ground u.s troops but
it would not surprise me if nato
coalition forces
were in there uh before too long
that's that's my that's my sense of it
right now
uh just just my opinion guys
take it for what you paid which is
nothing
nothing uh okay let's see what else we
got oh okay hold on a second marcy
barber is new member number 45 today
using the coupon code obama
marcy you have won an item from my
online store email info davidpakman.com
tell us what you'd like in your mailing
address and we'll get it out to you
um thanks to frostyrobot miggyrosay and
goofydaddy for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 48.
also thank you to lisa halvardson who is
new member number 49. i mean should i
give away another free item at 50 i
don't know i don't know i might be
losing out here
should we do a free item at 50 just
because it's a beautiful round number
people saying no don't do it
all right
people do want it okay
i'll give away another item from the
online store at 50. you can sign up at
joinpackman.com today's coupon codes are
cpac trash
please don't war
and obama people wondering what are the
oranges of obama and they are as follows
get a member is going to be in trouble
big trouble remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama
that's
that's where it's from okay that's the
that's the origin of that one for
everybody
who's wondering dear god i am traveling
to europe in may says dion prague vienna
bratislava should i cancel need advice i
i'm not gonna tell anybody what to do on
that
um
you're gonna have to make that decision
on your own my friend
but i don't envy the decision actually
i'm going to be go i announced recently
i am soon going to be going to florida
and florida i'm first going to go to
florida and do an interview on the
patrick bet david podcast we're going to
explain progressivism to patrickbetdavid
who said on his on his twitter
i want a progressive to have on the show
and i said i'll go and he said okay and
then i said okay and then we set it up
so i'm gonna be uh there
then after doing that interview i'm
gonna go down to florida
into the miami area and i will appear on
the best business show that's the name
of the show i'm not evaluating it uh
hosted by anthony pompliano and friends
and we will uh we'll be talking about
stuff pretty strongly there as well so
that's all happening i will be all over
miami i will be at blue ribbon sushi
i'm going to be everywhere it's going to
the sandwichery
uh where else am i gonna be miami's
great
miami's great
what other places do i like in miami
shepherd
for breakfast is good
oh stephen kenneth destiny bennell ii is
down there that's right i should meet up
with him
and molina destiny banel ii too
it's a good idea
sincere question i know nothing about
military operations could this be
somewhat resolved with a narrow raid
like bin laden are you saying to kill
putin
i mean listen i think if you assassinate
putin things change very quickly but i
don't think that that's even remotely
being discussed anywhere
anywhere
at this point in time
let's see what the atmosphere and
ambiance are like here partially because
of what's happening in eastern europe
but also okay we don't know
a lot of people uh coming in illegally a
lot of good people and also a lot of bad
people and
yep
okay we're watching all of it we're
watching all of it
david i can get you actually listen
here's a real thing i don't have
accommodations in miami yet if anybody
watching is in the hospitality industry
in miami and we would i mean if any
place wants to invite me you know
whatever i'll i'll always take a comp
stay or even discounted i mean whatever
you know miami beach is not cheap
miami beach they that you should see
what hotels cost down there
i should read the white house's latest
tweet okay let's see white house twitter
yeah no in all seriousness if you if
you're involved with any hotel you know
a nice hotel i mean please
uh
oh the latest tweet from the white house
is the swift decision yeah we already
went over that we went over that
yep
um have i watched any afpak yes it's
pretty bad
all right getting another free item
today
new member number 50 is leslie seal
leslie is new member number 50 signing
up today with the coupon code cpac trash
leslie please email info davidpakman.com
uh for your free item and there's a
bunch more people let's give out another
item at how about 66
um thank you to sir spammer some wolf
cult cow crapper dirty curta and then
may rican gifted five putting us at 59.
wow we're going to be at 66 before i
even
can sneeze
karen wing is number 60 today
jacob howe is number 61.
frank gilul is number 62.
trisha briggs number 63 marina wakefield
is number 64.
jeanette brooks is number 65 and the
next free item from the store goes to
martin hass
who is new member number 66 signing up
with the coupon code cpac trash all
right what's the next number where we
should give away a free item everybody
wants a free item at 69.
that's two on the nose
we're not going to do it as it's
childish guys give me a better number
how about 71 the year i was born is that
a good one
71
no let's do uh
all right let's let's do at 64 i will
give away another item let's see if
we're there already
el sarg is number 67.
doreen davies is number 68.
chris gillespie is number 69.
bill harris is number 70.
adam hanshaw is number 71.
darren gross is number 72. okay well
that's where we're at now 74 will get
the next item
let's yeah pump it up
other voice smells guys i don't know the
the voicemails are so delusional
i don't know
hey david uh just watched uh watching
your cpac coverage i've immediately
asked this question uh do you think that
trump praised putin for the invasion
because he had
plans to invade
or not really plans but he had you know
ideas who invade mexico mexico
protect the border
you know uh
man i i don't know i i doubt it
i don't think that that's i don't think
that that's anything no
uh
monday says dexy monday is my one year
anniversary of membership i joined a few
minutes before trump spoke at clown pack
2021 before he started you talked about
your second dose side effects thanks for
all you do well i don't even remember
that but i appreciate that i mean i
remember getting my second dose
all right
i think we're gonna make it to 74.
thanks to hannah reese who is new new
member number 73
and the next winner
is brandy scales new member number 74
using the coupon code please don't war
brandy if you'd like a free item mug
t-shirt hat whatever from our online
store email info davidpakman.com
i also want to say thank you to absolute
nonsense your billion miranda nicole and
gal ferguson for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 78. all
right what's the next number for a free
item
what's the next number for a free item
where it's 78
uh
100 no i'm willing to give uh oh i know
let's do 84 the year i actually was born
i was not really born in 1971. let's do
84. oh wait hold on it's trump oh here's
prump all right sorry to cut you
to short an american
[Music]
anyway let's see if we actually got to
84 already um thanks to rebecca kohl's
new member number 79
samsara living is 80.
daniel feldsbush is 81 edward wisniewski
82
travis levine 83 and the winner is vicki
hurd number 84 vicky please email
info
davidpakman.com
also thanks to blame space i am having
trouble keeping up with everybody's
names i apologize
let's listen guys i expect a very
corrosive speech
super chats will remain on screen during
the speech
[Music]
let me know in the comments do you
expect today's speech to be another
febrile screed from donald trump just
yes or no
yes or no it's fine
[Music]
to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Applause]
this is all i mean as if we needed a
reminder once not i mean we get the
reminders more frequently than this but
if you ever forget how sick and deranged
this right-wing movement is in the
united states cpac is a reminder of how
sick and deranged it is
[Music]
this song it's just it's it's everything
about it guys
[Applause]
wow
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you audio feedback it's great to
be back where it all started with the
great
patriots of cpac thank you very much
standing before you today i'm thrilled
to report that our incredible movement
a movement that
nobody's ever seen anything quite like
it there has never been anything like it
before true is strong and growing
stronger every single guys i think he's
sort of giving a state of the union
speech like he's still president the
radical left is exposed they're weak
and their pathetic policies have
been out there long enough now that we
don't want them we'll never take them
we are bringing back our country and we
are bringing back our freedom
the socialists globalists marxists and
communists who are
attacking our civilization have no idea
of the sleeping giant they have awoken
we are a sleeping giant
they cannot even begin to imagine the
birth is the audio okay or do we need it
up guys let me know in men and women
like all of you here today and this
we broke the is again
but they're going to find out the hard
way starting on november 8th
and then again even more so on
november 2024
they will find out like
here we go
we did it twice
and we'll do it again wow
a third time he
did he just say he's running two will be
the year that millions of everyday
citizens stand up
to the left-wing fascists
and they'll continue
and we will all continue together to
make america great again
we had it done the election was rigged
they've undone some of it not all of it
they'll never be able to do all of it
because we'll be acting long before they
can do all of it it was up to them
they'd do everything they could to
destroy our country
but we can build it back again quickly
and even better than before because
they have lost all credibility they've
proven during this period of time that
their policies are a disaster and that
their policies don't work
we'll get voter id we'll never defund
the police
ridiculous cancel culture will be wiped
out entirely
complete the wall in three weeks
took two and a half years on the wall
two and a half years to win
all of the litigation over 11 lawsuits
that they threw at us they were not
three weeks from finishing the wall
and then i said they can't be serious
they don't want to close up the little
loops
but nobody's ever had a border so secure
as the border that we had
we'll be sealed good and tight except
for people coming into our country
legally
this does seem like a campaign speech
the drugs pouring in the human
trafficking will stop
and we will again
save our country from destruction
[Music]
i want to thank the american
conservative union for putting on this
incredible
show this great program of patriots and
in particular
thank you to matt and mercedes schlapp
thank you very much
please proceed governor
matt and mercedes slap are truly vile
individuals
a uniquely negative influence on this
country tonight also and we have so many
that i'm going to leave some out it's
always a disaster when we do this
because they'll say sir
and it takes me a year
to make out sure sure
takes me a year because it's a year
before they sit before you again
but we'll give it the best we can i want
to thank and these are great people
these are our patrons senator rick
scott this is the same speech from 1933
i'm sorry from uh last month
you rick
senator bill hagerty
bill tennessee
great state of tennessee thank you bill
and john kennedy he's running it's not
going to be
much of an election he's gonna win so
easily
john whoa he's popular where's john
look at john
where is john great he does seem
particularly unhinged tonight
great student you know he's a great
student
comes from an incredible state the other
senator's not so good in that state i
must be honest
but john kennedy is fantastic
went to oxford you know that he went to
oxford he was an incredible student
brilliant guy and he's with us all the
way
also representatives
madison cawthon where's matt oh no
wow
madison
they're doing everything they can to
stop him
they're doing everything but that will
not be successful will it
mark green mark thank you it's becoming
vomitous thank you mark
thank you
[Applause]
a person who's very shy
doesn't like speaking her mind
but she does it anyway marjorie taylor
green
that is a freaking predator right there
where's marjorie
what a stupid song
[Applause]
a man that knows me almost better than
any human being
he knows every inch of me
what
what
and he thinks it's actually a very
beautiful sight that's why i like it
oh my god that's why i like him
he was the white extremely cult-like
and also
for obama and for bush
obama and i'd love to ask him who's in
the best shape
obama
obviously obama
kind of a question is that he
was also an incredible admiral highly
respected by everybody he was a great
admiral he had ever so he was a great
doctor
a great admiral and you know what he is
now he's an idiot incredible
loving
wonderful but very tough politician from
texas
congressman ronnie jackson thank you
ronnie
isn't this the worst guy i mean this is
an insane cult an insane cult
he said president trump is the
healthiest president in history if he
didn't eat junk food he'd live for 200
years that got us into a lot of trouble
right uniquely disqualifying statement
but that's okay
we all love you ronnie thank you great
job great job
a man who's terrific who really loves
our country and who's loved in the state
of florida matt gates where's matt uh
what
does trump know what gates is under
investigation for
thank you matt
good guy
former congressman and now happens to be
working on a little project called truth
social
which has been trending at the top all
over the place and it's going to give
our voice back
and he's tough as hell former
congressman
devin nunes
where is he still can't even pronounce
his name as you guys i'm sure would see
the last name is nunes with an s that's
the portuguese spelling z would be you
know the spanish origin spelling trump
still doesn't know the guy's name 128
and one in wrestling he was serious
don't wrestle him
a man who i mean every time he goes on
television it's like a fight is it jim
jordan he's got one point the other
point the other point
and there's nobody like him and if you
ever saw him work out he he just the
machine starts to burn the treadmill
start to go up on fire he's still in
great shape but he's a tough cookie
all-american wrestler
and nobody like him really there's
nobody like him congressman jim
jordan it's genuinely crazy jim jordan's
been accused of looking the other way
when there was sexual abuse going on in
the gym in the wrestling locker room
matt gates is under investigation for
child sex trafficking madison cothran's
been accused by like a dozen women of
sexual assault and harassment two she
said to two all-american wrestlers and i
said are you better than your father was
he said no sir nobody's better than my
father was that's a pretty that's only
your son could say that right right
paulie
jim thank you for being here great
people
and governor kevin stitt we know kevin's
tit yeah
governor stick
and by the way i noticed a patriot
in our midst
mike lindell where are you standing oh
no
oh no
pillow
any room that gives a standing ovation
to such a disgusting human being is a
room we need to write off
over two years he spent a whole life i
will tell you what he does and what he
goes through what he believes he's a
great patriot thank you mike very much
no closed captions here let me see if i
can get a different feed guys let's see
was that about right 22 years and people
loved her
and she's beautiful inside and out you
know you're not allowed to say that
anymore it's politically incorrect but
it's true she's beautiful inside and
they're not coming through even though
they're on i apologize like
very like everybody
and she is leading big
wow i just looked at a poll carrie and
[Music]
well you never know right so just keep
working
just keep working but you're leading
very big and you're doing a fantastic
job thank you very much and there's so
many other people here if i see him if
you don't mind during the course of a uh
the speech i'll just bring them out this
way it saves me a lot of problems
for the rest of the year or when they
vote against me at some point they'll
vote against me because i didn't mention
their name you know they're politicians
and they're vicious people
somebody said
sir you've been in business you've been
an entertainment the apprentice sir
in politics
who are the toughest two of the worst i
said the worst of the politicians
the toughest are the politicians
the meanest of the politicians
and the biggest lying scum of the
politicians
like
like adam shifty
schiff where do you meet people like
this
he actually made up a story about my
phone call with the president of ukraine
who by the way is a brave man he's
hanging in he's up at this
they've totally shifted the messaging
and i like them because you know during
that ridiculous impeachment waste of
time and the republicans stood by us
we were 196-0
when did you ever hear republicans do
that but this was truly a scam
but the president of ukraine said
he did nothing wrong he could have said
he did something or he thought well i
wasn't appropriate you know all the crap
you have to listen to right
he said
he did absolutely i called him up to
congratulate him on his victory he said
he did nothing wrong absolutely nothing
wrong i'm glad the tape
i'm glad that tape was going those
transcribers were writing during that
call because otherwise it could have
been but this is what we're dealing with
we're dealing with some people that are
truly evil truly bad people true
let me also express my enormous
gratitude to every single one of you
here today in the audience we appreciate
you being here it's a great crowd
that's a lot of people
and that's a lot of fake news look at
all those cameras up there wow
mexico
[Applause]
that's a lot of people and my friends
from north carolina they've come to 92
[Music]
our beautiful friends they've come to
nine i think it's 92 rallies and cpacs
and other things thank you all very much
sick people huh i don't know if their
husbands are happy about it but
but they are beautiful people they're
great people thank you very much thank
you for your dedication you know what
the bottom line they love our country
they love our country thank you
appreciate it
so we've been together from the very
beginning in this journey and
we are a long way from being done
because we had something very bad happen
and
we have to keep it going we're not going
to have a country left for
an amazing 48 years i don't know if you
guys are noticing but he's back to very
similar language and rhetoric as to when
he was running in 2016.
and this year we're being
vividly reminded how fragile and
precious that heritage really is i never
knew how important being president was i
was president for four years i think i
did a great job we did things that
nobody
did he never knew president was an
important job yeah
but
uh
the importance of the president when i
look at what's happening to our country
today the president is such an important
representative now we obviously know
that
but just
a wrong word or a wrong like a
yawn or going to sleep
very early like what's he talking about
no you just can't it's just such an
important
it's so important logically so important
for our country i never really realized
to that extent i knew it was important
but you assume you're going to be doing
certain things that are right we rebuilt
our economy and energy independence and
all of those things but you also have to
portray a strength to the outside world
otherwise they're going to walk all over
you and that's what they're doing right
now
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history
and put them together and they would not
have done the damage that joe biden's
administration has done
in just a very short 13 months
[Applause]
and no matter how you look at it our
country has totally
lost its self-confidence
lost its self-confidence we as a country
have no confidence anymore
but we will get it back and we'll get it
back stronger
than ever before
whoever heard of that
whoever heard of that our country has
lost its self-confidence whoever does
anybody know what's up with trump here
this is a very strange speech it's when
you see the way we withdrew
when you see the things that the
stupidity the open border concept who
wants this prisons from other countries
being emptied out
into our country just over one year ago
we had the most secure border in u.s
history
record low gas prices
american energy independence the fastest
economic recovery
in the history of our country fastest
economic recovery in history
and unrivaled military we rebuilt the
military and we added space force on top
of it
and peace and quiet
was all around the world
now inflation is the highest in 40 years
economists are talking about
five six seven and even eight dollar
a gallon gasoline
supply chains are crumbling
store shelves are empty
millions of illegal aliens are rushing
our borders
murders are setting records in our
cities
guys i don't know that any of this stuff
is true these are drenched in blood
erratica left zealot
has been nominated to the supreme court
of the united states lindsey graham
voted to confirm her
china is threatening taiwan
russia is decimating ukraine china iran
is on the cusp
of a nuclear bomb
we ended
the worst and most dangerous deal i've
ever seen and now they want to go back
to the iran nuclear deal america who's
even talking about the iran nuclear deal
humiliated in its surrender from
afghanistan and that's what it was it
was a surrender for no reason whatsoever
we wanted to get out but we had to get
out with strength and with dignity
and a major war in europe
may very well erupt that's how they
start exactly what's happening today
this is how they start
joe biden has turned calm into chaos
competence into incompetence
stability
into anarchy
and security
into catastrophe
the russian attack on ukraine is
appalling
it's an outrage
and an atrocity that should never
have been allowed to occur it never
would have occurred i guess now he's
against the invasion for the proud
people of ukraine god bless them all god
bless them
quite a 180 from two days ago on fox
news huh
and god bless thank you we are indeed
brave
as everyone understands this horrific
disaster would never have happened if
our election was not rigged
and of i
was the president oh my god very simple
wouldn't it happen
under bush
russia invaded georgia
under obama
russia
took crimea
under biden
russia
invaded ukraine
i stand as the only president of the
21st century
on whose watch russia did not invade
another country that doesn't necessarily
mean what trump wants you to think it
means
[Applause]
oh my god
thank you
i gave ukraine the javelins that
everyone is now talking about
and millions of dollars of other
military equipment the obama
administration gave them blankets you
remember they gave him by the way under
trump wasn't russia occupying um
the dunyet and luhansk regions and he
just like didn't even say maybe he
didn't even know it's a
peaceful place because america was
strong
and the perception of our country was
perhaps like it had never been before
powerful
cunning and smart we were a smart
country now we're a stupid country
we always very simply put america first
that was the answer
with the abraham accords
we had peace in the middle east
we had peace in europe
china knew that it could no longer take
advantage of the united states and i was
proud to be the first president in
decades who did not get our country into
any wars i got you out of wars
it's sort of like a very vague statement
which we we've picked apart before
it's it's not really accurate
by the way what war did he get us out of
thank you
under our administration
russia respected america
just like every other country respected
america and they really respected us a
lot
but trump thinks putin respected him as
a weak
and i hate to say it because i want him
to do a great job i really want him to
do politically i don't care
i would much rather have him do a great
job than a poor job
but nobody could ever believe
how bad and weak and grossly incompetent
it has been
and when you have a weak president who
is not respected by other nations you
have a very chaotic world and the world
hasn't been this chaotic since world war
ii i think we can say that we can say
that very strongly
i have no doubt that president putin
made his decision
to ruthlessly attack ukraine only after
watching the pathetic withdrawal from
afghanistan where the military was taken
out first our soldiers were killed
and american hostages plus 85 billion
dollars worth of the finest equipment
anywhere in the world were left behind
yesterday reporters asked me if i
thought president putin was smart
i said
of course he's smart to which i was
greeted with oh that's such a terrible
thing to say
i'd like to know this is smart
nato nations and indeed the world
as he
looks over what's happening
strategically
with no repercussions or threats
whatsoever they're not so smart they're
looking the opposite of smart if you
take this is quite a logic pretzel
trump's winding himself into with all of
the russia stuff
well that's a pretty weak statement
putin is saying oh they're going to
sanction me they sanctioned me for the
last 25 years you mean i can take over a
whole country and they're going to
sanction me
you mean they're not going to blow us to
pieces at least
psychologically
the problem
remember it used to be it's good to get
along with russia now it's why isn't
biden doing more to russia that our
leaders are dumb
yes
yes
that's true so dumb
and they so far allowed him to get away
with this travesty and assault on
humanity that's what it is this is an
assault on humanity so sad
putin is playing biden like a drum
and it's not a pretty thing as somebody
that loves our country to watch
just not a pretty thing to watch
you know i was
with putin a lot i spent a lot of time
with him i got along with him i got
along with president xi i got along with
kim jong-un we know all the dictators
massive nuclear power you loved all of
them
it's a good thing to get along with
people not a bad thing you can be very
tough and get along
you know i'm the one that ended his
pipeline he said you're killing me with
the pipeline nobody else ended his
pipeline biden came in he approved it
but i did a lot of things that were very
tough on russia nobody no president was
ever as tough on russia as i was and i'd
come in the fake news would say trump
loves russia he loves russia
which is now with durham and mueller and
all the rest just a total hoax it was a
made-up fictional story
completely bipolar speech on the russia
stuff i mean it's up down how it would
have been so easy for me to stop this
travesty from happening
he understood me and he understood that
i didn't play games this would not have
happened
someday i'll tell you exactly what we
talked about
but we talked about it and he did have
an affinity there's no question about it
for ukraine
i said never let it happen you better
not let it happen
this is the only attack in history where
the further he goes and the bigger it
gets then the worse it gets and the more
death that's caused the more money he
makes because oil prices keep climbing
higher and higher and higher there's
never been anything like that where
a warring nation
the more he makes it difficult to get
oil the more expensive it gets and the
more money he makes
and all those tanks roaming around are
very expensive but they're peanuts
compared to
the kind of money that he's making
because of the tremendous increase at
all you know when i
left
and during my term oil was at 36 a
barrel think of it 36
now it hit a hundred and they think it's
going to 150 so the middle east
and saudi arabia a lot of countries but
right now in particular is making more
money than they ever dreamed possible
the cost of the war is very very small
compared to the kind of money they're
taking and there's never been a
situation like that
it's uh
horrible to watch it's horrible because
it's a disincentive
for him to disengage remember
joe and hunter biden got 3.5 million
dollars from the mayor of moscow's wife
and were never allowed to explain
in the debate remember we had the debate
and i said hey
what do you do with the 3.5 million that
he got from the mayor of moscow's wife
wasn't that a lie so i assume was now
fired from fox which is good
he said that's not an appropriate
question that turned out to be another
one trump was right that turned out to
be another very
appropriate question he got three and a
half million dollars from the
mayor of moscow's wife very rich family
i will tell you that
this is a conflict of interest but at
the same time joe biden bragged
unknowingly on tape and this was on tape
can you imagine if i said it
about getting rid of a ukrainian
prosecutor or he wouldn't allow 1
billion dollars of american taxpayers
money to be given to ukraine they kept
saying where's the money where's the
money where's the money no you got to
get rid of that prosecutor he's getting
too close
can you imagine if i did that and he was
on tape and the fake news media those
people right there refused to report
and that's without mentioning the fact
that china gave them
1.5 billion dollars to manage and he
never managed money before other than
the money they got probably
there's plenty of confidence it seems
completely drunk
have to even think about it and the fake
news didn't
want to mention anything they didn't
want to talk about it
it was bad for the election it was bad
for
our country in their mind but they
probably knew talking about it would
have been good we can never really bring
our country back unless we get an honest
media because they're like the policing
agent
and they refuse to air scandal they
refuse to air it
that'll be interesting to see the
crowd's applause seems more geared
towards how trump trump's tone than what
he's saying
as one of the worst
scandals ever i call it the crime of the
century ballot harvesting as it gets
released and it's all over remember
obama gate was the crime of the century
then he we never again heard about
obamacare now it's ballot harvesting
through all of them for the job they've
done it's incredible but that'll be
released very soon everything is on tape
even the pictures are taken of the
people stuffing the ballot boxes because
without the pictures they don't get paid
it's all coming out soon about hundreds
of thousands of votes in each swing
state they focus they say on the swing
the swing states and you know what they
probably did others too
but the swing states was the focus over
the past year we've seen weakness
self-loathing and self-destruction
on a scale previously unthinkable
a military obsessed
with equity to all
and only being politically correct
i said so let me ask you is a general
good strong
general
general patton how do you think he'd
like this military
general douglas macarthur macarthur
would general patton be allowed to shout
at a private who was doing a horrible
thing
sir i we don't think that would be
appropriate oh really oh
sir sir i don't think jim jordan that
would work out too well would it huh it
wouldn't work out too well
a department of homeland security
actively aiding illegal immigration in
many cases criminals coming into our
country
criminals absolute criminals the
department of energy and interior
forcing us to be reliant on foreign
energy at a cost that is not acceptable
to our nation and not sustainable
serious question are there any actual
generals who who like trump and think
he's smart
as grave as the dangers are abroad
it's the destruction
within that spells our doom
we must get this
reversed our most dangerous people
are people from within these are people
that must hate our country
because they make us weak
and they make our country unsustainable
as a nation itself unbelievably biden is
now claiming
that you must sacrifice through higher
energy prices
to foot the cost of his failed foreign
policy in europe
i saw john kerry on television
and we're talking about energy we need
energy we need oil we need gas we need
everything
no no no
no no global warming global warming
we have a world that's ready to blow up
and disintegrate over energy and he's
talking about global warming
the oceans may rise over the next 300
years one one hundredth of an inch
wow
giving you slightly more seafront
property that's
and this is his problem he's not
thinking about the nuclear warming he's
thinking about
other types of warming
these people are not living in a world
of reality
the reason we've festering gas prices is
that biden shut down american energy
canceled our oil and gas leases just two
days ago
two days ago they canceled many oil and
gas leases because of the environment
how great would it have been if during
that little press conference he did
someone said uh mr president sir you
said under biden people would be
flushing toilets 10 to 15 times are you
doing that proving
the russian pipeline which has really
been at the core of much of the problem
we have right now
and i fought angela i said angela
here is a white flag happened to be a
white napkin that was on my desk
i said angela you can have it she said
but why but why
i said because you're getting 75 and i
think it's higher than that but it will
be
75 of your energy from russia and as you
probably know through history you've had
some
rather major conflicts
with russia and if you ever have a
conflict with russia you will be able to
wave the white flags guys out of his
mind and surrender
because they supply your energy
and uh
i knew that would happen i just never
had any idea was going to happen so fast
and did she say sir completing with opec
and begging iran to re-enter the
disastrous nuclear deal
[Music]
with biden you get
a war in europe
and a war on
american energy with republicans you get
energy independence and energy dominance
we were still by the way energy
independent in 2021 i just had that
report last week on the bonus show
and by the way by independent what we
mean is we produced equivalent to usage
but it doesn't mean energy is still not
being traded internationally i mean
that's why these talking points are just
so meaningless
72 years i was very proud of that they
ended it almost immediately
we would have been
bigger
than russia and saudi arabia
combined times two in one year we were
already bigger we were doing things that
we had never done before
and
we should not be buying
russian energy but rather allow the
people of our country to start producing
like they did just one year ago
that's all we have to do
this will drive prices down
drive inflation down you want to get rid
of inflation or bring it way down
reduce the cost of energy that's a
single biggest factor having to do with
inflation
[Applause]
and what has happened in ukraine is a
catastrophic disaster
but it isn't
really
that interesting that
so many democrat politicians in
washington
they seem to be rushing to microphones
to declare that ukraine's borders are
sacred they want to say their borders
are sacred
and we feel for ukraine in so many ways
but
ukraine's sovereignty must be
defended at all costs they say
even while they're destroying our own
borders and surrendering our own
do you think he doesn't understand the
difference between putin sending tanks
in
to take over a country while killing
people
and someone coming in from mexico
undocumented to work do you guys think
he doesn't realize those are two
different things
with the plane remember they said oh the
planes are coming in the people that
rushed the planes those are very
energetic people he doesn't care people
that fair you will be paying a big big
price for
in years to come
the most important duty of every elected
lawmaker is to protect and defend
america and that begins with protecting
and defending america's borders
at first i thought he was on an upper
but now he seems more sedated yeah
under joe biden we're losing our country
no different than if we had lost it in a
war
no different
no different
millions of people are pouring in
descending on our communities camping in
our towns
depleting our resources
flouting our laws and bringing crime
drugs and death
to the streets of our cities and
communities
and they're not only coming from central
and south america they're coming from
all over the world over
160 countries
in many cases from jails that are being
emptied into our country
as though we are a dumping ground
we're not the united states we're
considered a dumping ground for a big
massive dump the biden administration
has spent months
obsessing over how to stop an invasion
of a foreign country
thousands of miles away
i believe americans deserve a president
who will stop
the invasion
of our country also
and we had it stopped one year ago
we had it stopped
we had it stopped one year ago you can't
defend western civilization
if you would not be able to defend
your own civilization
and that means we need borders that work
elections that are fair and free and not
rigged and crime that must be
immediately stopped in our cities
and we must immediately stop the influx
of illegal aliens has to stop
immediately our country is being
poisoned from within
[Applause]
the biden administration cares
more about helping citizens of a distant
foreign nation
than it does about our own citizens
because our country is a mess our
country is a dangerous place and it's
getting worse and worse every day and
when you hear three million people this
year it's not three million it's
probably three to four times that number
it's probably 10 million 11 million or
12 million but the real truth is they
have no idea wait so is trump saying
that this year 11 million people are
coming in because the belief is that 11
million people are here undocumented
total he's saying another 11 million are
coming in just in one year
never heard that before they should
start with the democracy that is under
threat
right next door
a place called canada
well by the way we
got rid of nafta and we have the usmca
that's mexico and basically the same
thing one of the greatest deals we've
ever made and i know it's great because
they want to renegotiate the deal
that was a horrible deal nafta was the
worst trade deal ever made and now we
have probably the best trade deal ever
made but they want to renegotiate the
the differences between nafta and usmca
are quite subtle putting america first
we put america first it's a great deal
they should leave it
they've been ripping us off for 30 years
it's time for us to do well the tyranny
we have witnessed in canada in recent
weeks should shock and dismay people all
over the world
in an advanced western democracy the
peaceful movement of patriotic truckers
workers and families protesting for
their most basic rights and liberties
has been violently put down
their assets and life savings have been
frozen
they have been slandered as nazis
racists and terrorists these are the
names they've been called
they've been arrested and shown listen
there were some nazi flags and many of
the organizers are connected to white
nationalists powers i watched them i saw
those maple leafs all over the flags and
the love for their country plenty of
americans were there too and they love
our country
they're being hunted down like enemies
of their own government and treated
worse than drug dealers and murderers or
rapists
a line has been crossed
you're either with the peaceful truckers
or you are with the left-wing
fascists and that's what's been
happening and it's been a strong by the
way do you think anyone in the room
understands the absurdity of the term
left-wing fascists
to reclaim their freedom
thank you
thank you
thank you very much and thank you linda
good job
right here in our own nation
it's also far past time to declare
independence from every last covet
mandate it's time
maybe you can maybe you can't i'm not a
doctor
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something and you know
as early as when it first happened
i let the governors make that decision
and we had some governors that did a
great job and we had some governors that
didn't do a very good job but i can tell
you that the republican governors did
quite well thank you quite well
donate plasma
and a big big difference also on crime
you look at where the crime is and you
don't see the word republican very much
if at all with one voice americans must
insist that
the emergency is over this guy is a
[ __ ] to this left-wing tyranny no
longer we will not the funny thing is
are there any mask mandates left like
the the remaining mandates are mostly
uh
stores and and municipalities and then
the travel mandate they'll get some
votes but we will never forget what they
did to our children we will hold them
accountable at the ballot box this
november
as everyone here understands the covet
mandates are just one part of a
much larger crisis the radical left is
trying to replace american democracy
with woke
tyranny
they want to do the same thing to
america
that trudeau has been doing to canada
and much much worse
[Applause]
our mission in
2022
and in 2024
is to take on this radical and power
hungry ruling class and to deliver them
an electoral defeat so resounding that
they are exiled into political oblivion
never ever to return again wow
joe biden chuck schumer and crazy nancy
pelosi are the
sinister faces of this corrupted lawless
political establishment
they enrich their families in ukraine
china russia while they shutter your
small businesses right here at home
they send young americans to fight and
die for the borders of distant foreign
nations while they throw our borders
open to an illegal foreign invasion
which is what is happening
they said violent criminals loose
without charges while prosecuting their
political opponents
for fabricated crimes here's the
dehumanizing language of saying people
were set loose almost like you set a
wild animal loose
ransacking our cities while they
hold non-violent protesters without
trial destroy their lives
they lift sanctions on iran
while they sanction and destroy our own
citizens
they try to silence voices like joe
rogan for alleged misinformation
perpetuate the most flagrant hoaxes and
monstrous lies like the
russia-russia-russia hoax how was that
for three years we had to put up with
the russia russia russia hoax it was a
total hoax
they indoctrinate your children to hate
their parents
while calling you a hateful racist
they stick
the fbi on mothers at school board
meetings while they teach four-year-olds
to
pick their own genders
would you like to change your gender
and they say it's a very stable genius
[Music]
for a boy or man to participate in
women's sports i don't think so
[Applause]
one of the notable characteristics of
trump's speeches in 2022 has been
some transphobia at every single speech
pensions agencies to frame you
they use the media to slander you they
use the legal system to persecute you
you is a persecution
they rig elections
to disenfranchise you and destroy you
and
ruin your lives i've seen the anger and
the hatred and the
horror
horror the 2020 election it's hara wow
they claim as they are the ones
defending democracy they say they are
the ones that are going to defend your
democracy and your justice
it's a lot of [ __ ] that's what it is
stand back and stand by
i have to interrupt with an incredibly
positive message of peace and love
andrew dale on twitch has now been
subscribed 30 months which is incredible
subtitles are on guys they're just not
coming through they're
they're on they're just not coming
through store constitutional government
of by and for the people
the washington swamp knows that we are
coming to break their grip on power
forever that is why they are so
desperate to stop us they will go to any
length
and that is why the corrupt democrat
prosecutors an unconstitutional
unselect committee on january 6. the
unselect committee
can you imagine a committee made of
these thugs
they hate us all
is there ever been a committee like this
the unselect committee i think that was
my term i think i came up with it first
i'm very proud
of many of our attorneys
but they're continuing their evil and
demented persecution of me my family my
staff my supporters and you
one of the funny things about a trump
speech is there's no rhyme or reason
like you can basically tune in any time
and it makes equally little sense and
everything just seems out of context and
people go oh i must have just missed the
context that would have made this all
clear it's like no no no there is no
such context
now we know that crooked hillary
not only spied on my campaign that's not
true she spied on the white house
completely untrue
a lot of people getting banned by the
way
throwing the hell out of here
you remember when i said years ago
i think they spied in my campaign
and everybody said on the other side how
dare he say that
how dare he well it turned out to be
true it's as much of a lie now as it was
though john durham for
figuring that out
remember durham put out a statement
saying uh yeah i didn't say any of that
stuff
[Music]
very bad things are going to be learned
about what took place everything they're
doing to me
is about preserving their power and
control over the american people
if i renounce
my beliefs if i agreed to stay silent
if i stayed at home
if i said i'm not going to run
the persecution would stop immediately
what they'd go on to the next victim
that's not true who's next
but they'll never ever do
what they did to me and nobody else i
don't believe would be able to take it
if they did
i have had that a lot
i've had great people come up to me and
tell me sir ma'am please ask you a
question
yes sir would you like to have time
magazine again
how did you take it how did you take it
i don't even know
but there's never been anything like
this ever done to an american president
before
but i can't
do any of those things because i love
this country we love this country and
we're going to bring this country back
and it's going to be bigger and better
and stronger
than ever before so i guess he's running
but remember they're coming after me
because i'm standing up for you and that
is it i'm standing up for you
in 2022 we're taking on this
wretched and corrupt political
establishment like never before and
we've learned a lot over the last four
years we've learned how corrupt they are
nobody can even believe it if you wrote
a book or a novel
and it was all just printed out like
this
with crooked hillary
with
the mueller report
what no one would believe is if it was
included in the screenplay that trump
was flushing documents down the toilet
and publicly talking about flushing
toilets any any director would be like
that that's totally unbelievable we
can't include that and yet it's true
it's treason it's everything you can
have if anybody ever wrote
a novel the great james patterson have
you ever wrote a novel like this on
yourself because people would say no no
it's not believable this could never
happen
guy who hasn't read a book in 40 years
talking about novels now things now that
nobody even thought were possible
we're going to end nancy pelosi's
political career once and for all no
you're not dude
who's gonna do it
and then we're going to kick the biden
crime family out of the white house in
2010
isn't that the best like what crimes
what crimes dude
but even our supreme court justices and
it's sad to say this
are afraid to do what has to be done to
save our country
they're trying so desperately to be
politically correct
and to be loved by all they're cowering
in fears of the united states supreme
court the overwhelmingly conservative
supreme court left
they are afraid of packing the court
so that they're only one of 15 19 or
even 25 justices
and at any cost they don't want to be
impeached please don't impeach me i
don't want to be a beach of a supreme
court judge please don't impeach me
i'm a justice of the supreme court don't
impeach me please for
being with the women that i never heard
of before
he's with the women
what women that he didn't know women
that
a particular justice kavanaugh had no
idea
who they were but you know and we will
ban
men
and he's afraid i believe he's afraid i
believe he's afraid to do that i guess
he's ridiculing women who said they were
sexually assaulted ref they play the ref
they said not so long ago we're going to
impeach him
for something and then they found out
the woman got up she said well he never
did anything wrong they said we don't
care we're going to impeach him anyway
none of this is just people
these are vicious people and we can't
let this go on they have to gain
strength they have to gain newborns i
don't know i mean kavanaugh was very
strong in his denials just like putin
they can no longer be afraid of the
radical left our supreme court and our
judges generally
the work of making america great again
is only just beginning the republicans
have
a big and bold agenda
that they're going to put into action
under a republican congress and we have
a chance of setting records but i don't
want to say that
i don't want to say we could win 65
seats because if we win 64 they'll say
it was a terrible night for trump
[Applause]
terrible
he had a horrible night he only won 64.
he said he wanted 65.
we will bring joe biden's
inflation-causing socialist spending
spree
to a screeching halt
we will immediately begin a full audit
of the six trillion dollars of radical
democrats i do believe if trump wins the
socialism will end in the sense that
there is currently no socialism they
want to get up to a number that nobody
can believe and looks like maybe
people will not allow that to happen
because they don't want our country to
be destroyed
they should have never ever in the
senate given that two-month stay
you had them on the ropes you were going
to win
and then mitch mcconnell
gave them a two-month stand wow
cpac booing mitch
i call it the two months in which they
can get their act together
and then they voted for the
on i call it the un infrastructure bill
because there was very little
infrastructure right and then we found
nine percent infrastructure most of it's
like throwing the money right out the
window
and they voted what a [ __ ] is headed by
mitch mcconnell he's so bad for our
country the american people deserve to
know
where did all the money go in addition
we must take immediate action to fight
the biden violent crime wave that is
devastating our citizens in democrat-run
city how did he say biden there boyerdon
that was strange huh
i mean in afghanistan
i had a meeting with abdul you know
abdullah is he's the leader of the town
remember when he used to say the meeting
was with muhammad he doesn't know who he
met with guys
i went i was much tougher than that i
want to be nice
that much
even jim jordan
[Applause]
but i said abdul you're killing
ourselves jesus you better i cannot kill
ourselves
what an edgy president if you do you
will be hit
like no country has ever been hit you
will be hit harder than anybody has ever
been
and he said mr president but why
he actually called me your excellency i
don't know do you think he calls
biden your excellency sir i don't know
he goes but why your excellency mr
president
do you send me a picture of my house
this never happened
and i said i'd rather not answer that
question see i was being very well see
i'm being diplomatic this is a
completely imaginary story this never
happened sir
and you know we didn't have one soldier
killed
in 18 months in afghanistan we had them
we had them
this is what we won the taliban
and we could have pulled out
with strength and dignity they were
absolutely and then you look at what's
happening in new york and chicago and
los angeles and these democrat-run
cities
and you have
seven people killed in one weekend and
80 shot
it's terrible republicans should pass
legislation making clear that when how
did we get i mean it's it's
the top it's completely erratic jumping
from one topic to another criminals
the da's and attorney generals can
be charged with violations of the civil
rights law
the civil rights law
the i like that which
i mean look at los angeles what's going
on look at philadelphia
where people that kill
violent criminals are being immediately
allowed out of
jail with no bond
as we defend america's safety we must
also defend american values as president
i was proud to issue the world's first
ban on critical race theory in september
2020.
it was over
he proudly issued the first ban on it
and then biden with the help of mitch
mcconnell
came into office remember he signed 17
executive orders and one of them unended
it
not good i also created the 1776
commission you people would love the
1770s
so that young americans would learn to
love this country
as much as we in this room do
on his first day in office
biden abolished the
1776 commission and then proceeded to
impose woke left-wing racism
on our military with biden enacted woke
and for all banned critical race theory
from our schools we will ban it from our
military we will ban it from every
institution that accepts a single penny
from the federal government
america's history will be taught fully
and truthfully
to america's beautiful children
in addition
we must defend
parents rights something new uh-oh
something new
meaningless
that's right something new that came up
parents rights whoever thought of
parents rights parents writes we love
our parents of course now we have to
defend parents trump really cares about
the rights of parents to do things if
ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps i'd
be dating her go over anyone teaching
far left gender ideologies to their
children without
parental consent
and any parent who objects to the
radical indoctrination in their
children's classroom should be able to
take their share of taxpayer dollars and
spend it
at the public private charter or
religious school of their choice destroy
public schools is what that means
another top priority to save american
democracy must be to break up the big
tech giants and restore
free
speech in america
and we'll be fighting that very hard
by opening truth social
the days of big tech censoring the
voices of the american people
are numbered the left is also trying to
take away the rights and dignity of oan
one america news on directv and at t and
it's a great voice and these are great
people and they're patriots he still
doesn't understand what's happening with
oan notice shut down and shut down and
it does great who listens to oan i do
i do they want to take away their voice
can't let it happen
they've got millions of viewers and
those
viewers oan doesn't have millions of
viewers that's crazy
well we're at it a republican congress
should launch a select committee as
opposed to an unselect committee
to get to the bottom of big tech's
2020 election interference
let's find out who made the decision to
censor
who made that decision to censor
the joe and hunter biden
corruption bombshell which the pollsters
said amounted to about 15 points
the largest illegal campaign uh
15 points
it was a bogus story so no one ran with
it is what happened
417 million dollars given by mark
zuckerberg who used to come to the white
house and kiss my ass zuger
that they spent to take over local
election offices and key democrat
counties and i believe you're going to
be hearing a lot of it
you know if you're a person
that wants to make a contribution
you're allowed to give less than six
thousand dollars
otherwise they put you in jail
he gave 417 million dollars what the
hell is it
what are we doing
six thousand dollars and you go to jail
417 million dollars spread all over them
now understand that
i'm i'm ready to reform the way pax and
all of it works i'm i'm ready
but
he only cares about those limits when it
doesn't benefit him turnout efforts
illegal drop boxes and ballot harvesting
that's taken place
when other bundlers and super pacs are
putting together 200 million that helps
trump he suddenly doesn't care about
that percent
for joe biden because he campaigned so
hard from his basement
three percent for trump
three percent they gave me three at
least they gave me something because i
think they had a couple where he
actually got a hundred percent
thousands of votes he got a he got four
thousand i got nothing
no
it's uh that was such a horrible thing
we need fair elections you need those
borders you need those elections
the world is already waiting to see the
explosive information out of georgia
where through the vote incredible people
has uncovered a massive any day now the
evidence is coming out guys two thousand
ballot stuffers or as they call them
mules they call it it's almost sad now
stuffers these are people they call them
mules
ballots in georgia and other swing
states were trafficked and sold on
an unprecedented scale
and the brutality and
it was just incredible what took place
it's like it's so weaponized and
corrosive but it's also so impossible to
take it even remotely seriously because
it's so stupid got them at the machine
standing here here they are here they
are you know why because that's the way
they got paid they had to take a picture
of them
and what job they've done
what a job they call them
the hardest thing to do
isn't to have caught them it's to get
those people to write anything about
them because without the fake news
you don't have a scandal
the rhinos and certain weak republican
politicians want to ignore election
integrity also
but we cannot ignore it and we have to
fix it
make no mistake they will
try to do it again in 22 and 24 and we
cannot let them do that and the way
you do it is to come to a very powerful
conclusion as to what happened in 2020
right
and in a few years we'll finally know
i'm sure to stand down to stop talking
about it
to stop making americans aware of the
cheating and corruption that went on
[Music]
that's really saying
it's okay you can do it again we can't
let that happen
in addition to securing our elections
here are just some of the other things
we must do with republicans
back in charge
we must pass
critical reforms making every executive
branch employee
fireable
by the president the deep state must
and will
be brought to heal
what
what we will stop the radical democrats
from packing the supreme court
with far left justices they haven't even
tried to
although the way the supreme court is
behaving
perhaps the republicans should pack the
supreme court
wait they are behaving not the way we
think is appropriate for our country
that doesn't make sense as a lot of
people have suggested that but i don't
think we'll do it and we will defend the
constitution the right to life and the
right to keep and bear arms
that exists already
we will end sanctuary cities
we will end catch and release and we
will end the visa lottery scam and we
will finish the wall very quickly a
matter of weeks
none of it will happen we will charge
china trillions of dollars for
unleashing the virus upon the world
china
will place tariffs and other countries
we will do
the tariffing thing we have no choice
we're going to do the tariffs guys
china for years they ripped off our
country
they paid hundreds of billions of
dollars
during our
time in office they never paid 10 cents
never 10 cents between tariffs and taxes
hundreds of billions of dollars and you
know we made a trade deal and it was an
incredible deal for our farmers and our
manufacturers that's why our farmers are
doing so well because china now i
understand that china be once i'm out
china's not going to adhere to the deal
he has no idea what he's saying
but they're not going to hear but the
farmers did fantastically well but we
made incredible
deals with china we saved our steel
industry because they were dumping steel
all over our country our steel industry
was going down the tubes i've had so
many people in the steel undersea thank
me for the job we did we put massive
tariffs on steel that they were dumping
in our country
but we took in hundreds of billions of
dollars from china nobody else took in
10 cents over many many years and i'm
very proud of it and china respected us
and then of course
when covid or the china virus came in we
had to deal with
my daughter uh we're very proud of the
job we did we did something that i don't
think anybody else could have done and i
want to thank certain governors did a
very good job certain republican
governors did a very good job certain
and i can't think of any democrat
governor that did a good job they were
all in lockstep let's lock up your
cities let's lock up your towns let's
lock up your state
and let's harm your children you can
tell trump's deeply spiritual from this
speech
age
we will place tariffs on other countries
to restore the glory of american
manufacturing and we will ensure our
future is made
right here we're going to manufacture we
started it big time right here in the
usa
and these are just a few of the steps
that we have to take what a lunatic to
save the nation
that we love the rest of them you know
the rest of them we've discussed today
if we fail in our mission we've been
speaking about 75 minutes america will
be the radical left is trying to
extinguish our very identity as
americans
so that when they try to take our
freedom
we do not even think to resist now what
when will they take our freedom i guess
is the question they got to fight
we have no choice we got to fight like
hell we can't let them destroy our
country
but our opponents have made a very big
mistake they have done the one thing you
must never do
if you seek to harm america they have
grossly underestimated the strength and
brilliance and pride of the american
people they're not going to stand for it
they're not going to take it
the crackdown censorship and cancel
culture are not an expression of
confidence they are an expression of
cowardice and of fear and they are
afraid
they reveal not the dominance of the
radical left but their desperation and
their despair
they are losing we are winning they know
it they know it and that's why they're
going so far that's why they're doing
some of the crazy things that they're
doing
they're acting
as though they were lunatics
maniacs and the people get it and we
have to stop it and we have to stop it
now my fellow americans this nation does
not belong to the radicals and it does
not belong to
the corrupt establishment in washington
that i've gotten to know very well
this nation
belongs to you belongs to you
really inspirational speech
it was patriots like you that
built this country
and it's patriots like you that are
going to save our country
so to all of those who think
that they can coerce and subjugate
the citizens of this land
hear these words
from me tonight
mexican people of america will not
surrender our borders
we will not surrender our culture we
will not surrender our faith we will not
surrender our values we will not
surrender our history
we will not surrender our liberty and
above all we will not surrender our
children to the small band of bullies
and extremists who want to tell everyone
else
what to do
really struggling to read the prompter
now
we are done with the fascists and
communist and socialists and we are done
with their distorted vision good thing
there's barely barely any in the country
i guess makes it easy to be done with
them greatness for our country again we
want our country to be great again we
want our country to be respected again
we are a laughingstock all over the
world today one year ago
we were respected like never before
there is no poll you can find that
supports what he's saying right now in
closing as your president
i instituted
okay
please proceed governor
i instituted the largest tax cut in
american history by far
and our economy thrived like never
before
as your president i eliminated more
burdensome regulations than any other
president
in history
name them as your president i proudly
protected our constitution
and the first and second amendment
as your president i secured our southern
border upheld the laws of this land and
stop the influx of illegal immigrants
into america very dangerous illegal
immigrants i instituted the remain in
mexico policy we don't want you here you
have to remain in mexico
and mexico agreed with us
someday i'll tell you that story
built over 500 miles of border wall and
ended the insanity of catch and release
as your president i made america energy
independent for the first time in 72
years
when i left office
america was a net exporter of energy for
the first time in our country's history
as your president i negotiated free and
fair trade deals with canada mexico
japan
all over europe and china
we had the worst trade deals ever and we
turned them into some of the greatest
trade deals ever made i'm the only
president in history to stand up to
china and they're one-sided unfair trade
practices that's not true and i tax them
and i tariff them beyond any levels that
anybody thought was possible and you
know what president xi
liked me and respected me and i liked
and respected him we got along great we
got along great until covet came and
then
it was a whole different
but we had a very good relationship as
your president i kept my promise and
chose supreme court justices
on the list i gave to the country before
the 2016 election yeah who he just
railed against instead of doing a
terrible job conservative justices
as your president i insisted nato
nations start paying their fair share
and they did hundreds of billions of
dollars started floating in
hundreds of billions of dollars
and secretary general stoltenberg was my
biggest fan he said i've never believed
it because
president obama would go to nato
make a speech
talk about the weather the sun how
lovely everyone looks at lee
and others would too including president
bush how wonderful everything was and i
went and i said
i'm sorry you're all delinquent you have
to pay
they said
none of this is true meanwhile uh there
is big breaking news out of ukraine and
we're gonna get to it um momentarily
it's it's it's wild what's happening
floating billions and billions of
dollars flowed in
these are stories that the fake news
doesn't want to talk about
i also warned nato about the danger of
russia
and look at the consequences on foreign
policy
the world rightly had a healthy fear
that as president
i would stand strong for
american priorities you remember though
when so many people in the democrat
party and during the debates
said he's going to get us into the third
world war with trump i'm the one that
didn't have any wars i'm the one
that got us out of wars look at iraq
look at syria i was the one that brought
us way down
in afghanistan i brought you down to
2000 soldiers the easy part was just
getting out i brought it down from 20
000 soldiers to 2 000 soldiers the easy
part was for biden to just get them out
let the soldiers stay the remaining
soldiers and take care of everything
it's called
soldiers out last i went to a child who
was five years old
you've heard me say this i said let me
ask you a question i gave him the whole
story
would you take the soldiers out first or
would you take them out last i'd take
them out last
he was five and he understood
they understood any hostile actions
would be met with swift and severe
consequence
the world is always safer when america
has a strong president
america has to be strong and it needs
strong leadership and you see what
happens when you have
bad weak or incompetent leadership it's
a travesty like nobody could believe
could happen in such a short period of
time the world is always in danger with
a weak american president this coming
midterm election is more critical than
ever before
i'm asking all of you to fight and work
hard to elect candidates that believe in
the principles and policies that we hold
so dear
this is a long speech
for the country
and the stakes dude i've got miso soup
and katsu coming i need this to wrap is
not an option
we must win in 2022
we must win in 2024
we all know what happens
when you get a rigged election
like in 2020 will never happen again
we all know laws were not followed
ballot harvesting was rampant we all
know state constitutions were also
ignored all over our country and you're
not allowed to do that the only ones
that can make the changes hey just as a
quick thing i know this is the most
important thing going on but at such
difficult and complicated times as these
i always wonder what would tulsi do and
tulsi has now put out another statement
president putin you've made your point
before it's too late stop the attack now
i have both ukrainian and russian
friends and i know that they have aloha
they have respect and love for each
other like brothers and sisters
it's clear that the russian people and
the ukrainian people both just want to
live in peace so
i implore you
end this assault now before it gets to
the point of no return and the suffering
becomes unimaginable what a principled
and defiant statement from tulsi
and why anyone would even remotely care
what she has to say at this point i
really couldn't tell you dated and they
must be accurate
not changed after the election takes
place
we must seek a goal of voter id
this is a goal we have to seek this is
what we should have
voter id
same day voting like we've always done
no mail in ballots except for our
military and people who are truly sick
trump voted by mail guys wonderful too
what would be really wonderful it's
asking a lot a thing called very simply
paper ballots
i have a young son baron
young son and he can make
his computer sing
i turn it off and i lock it
two minutes later hi dad how you doing i
was like what are you doing yeah i know
how to get it open dead
isn't barron like 17 that's how he talks
very bad things happen
i can't imagine trump has any idea what
baron's up to it goes to paper ballots
you know that right canada paper ballots
america is the greatest country on earth
and we must insist on integrity in the
process so we are confident of the
results because what we have now is you
have 80 percent of
the party thinking the vote was a
horrible vote and i believe that to be
the case i've i know certainly i feel
certain that it was you can't have that
you can't have a great democracy
with a thing like that happening you
must
get your state legislatures to act now
before november they have to move they
have to act with the help of everyone
here today and with the commitment of
hard-working freedom-loving patriots all
across our country
we will make
america powerful again oh no
we will make america wealthy again
here we go
we will make america strong again and we
will we will make america proud again we
want to be proud again
we will make
america
safe again
and we
will make america
great again
thank you very much thank you god bless
you all thank you
[Music]
well it was indeed another febrile
screed by donald trump
he told lies
he struggled through the teleprompter
reading
he um he he really did it all
[Music]
and remember
if it's just trump in a room by himself
okay
it doesn't say as much about the country
but it's trump in a room of sycophants
who are absolutely salivating for
another run
[Music]
sorry i think there's more people i had
there's just so many people i think
we've banned like 40 people during this
stream
it's weird
[Music]
it's like just go watch somewhere else
there's the dancing trump's eye are
notably swollen shut as usual
what an insane situation
[Music]
one of the things i will be talking
about this week are uh i'm gonna go
through some of the tools of
reactionaries and one of the tools of
reactionaries is the imaginary slippery
slope
next thing you know if they keep going
down this road
[Music]
the vaccine one has interestingly been
proven wrong i mean it's like we had the
first vaccine mandate when george
washington required soldiers to be
inoculated then we had a vaccine mandate
in cambridge massachusetts in 1905 and
then there was uh mil yeah and it just
it's never gone beyond every once in a
while we add vaccines as we develop them
um and but they they insist on it they
just insist on it endlessly it's always
it's about to happen it's about to
happen and it never does
and the imaginary slippery slope as a
tool of fear for the reactionary
is something we're going to be talking
about
quite frankly we're going to be talking
about it pretty strongly this week
looking at that very strongly yeah
so um i really appreciate everybody who
joined me i appreciate the
116 people who either made a twitch
prime subscription or signed up on my
website we will be back on monday with
the state of the show address
leading up to
tuesday night
joe biden's state of the union address
and it is all going to be happening
and quite frankly i can't really imagine
a better place to be
i really can't i really can't
uh if you're watching over on twitch we
are going to raid our friend grandmaster
hikaru nakamura
let's head on over there let's do it
guys let's just do it
um and otherwise the stream will come to
an end
at this point in time thank you
you